well nuclear power has had a difficult
history of course in the 60s and 70s we
had a boom in nuclear power around the
world everybody hoped the famous phrase
was it was going to be too cheap to
meter but then of course we had the
accidents at Three Mile Island in the
United States and the very serious
accident in Chernobyl in Ukraine and
that really set the industry back
dramatically we had reached the point
until very recently where we had not
actually done a new grassroots nuclear
reactor for 30 years but now there is
talk of a global nuclear renaissance and
whether it's as grandiose in the United
States as some people would believe it
certainly is going to be worldwide the
Chinese have 24 reactors under
construction another hundred plan the
Indians have very vigorous programs for
the future the Russians there's growing
interest in the Middle East and the
United Arab Emirates Saudi Arabia Egypt
so we're going to see this the big
question in my mind is as we expand
nuclear power we need to make sure we do
it in a way that we not only do it
safely obviously but we also need to be
I think of growing concern about
enhanced risks of nuclear weapons
proliferation that the civilian nuclear
technology not being misused in any way
and as we have more of these sensitive
facilities potentially for what we call
uranium enrichment and reprocessing
which are part of the fuel cycle which
you need for atomic civilian power but
once you have one or both of those
technologies you de facto have the
capability of making a weapon and I
don't think most of us going to worry
you know if developed countries that are
considered highly stable expand nuclear
power but as we start moving nuclear
reactors into the Middle East and other
politically volatile regions of the
world we certainly want to make sure
that all the vendors that sell this
equipment are as vigilant as possible to
make sure that somehow under a dual-use
item that's said to be used for one
thing that it can't be used
another and it's a very very serious
problem